You see because what happens is many
Muslims and Christians as
well because they have the knowledge of
whatever they have been taught in terms
of salvation they they stop there. So
they're not willing to learn anymore.
You understand what I'm saying? So for
example when I'm handing out my leaflets
in the street wherever I am somebody's
coming by a Muslim Muslim brother and I
say here can I give you one here even in
his mind he's saying no already because
I know already where I'm going. Even
though in his life he may be doing
things that are contrary to the will of
the almighty but he's doing he knows
okay because I'm Muslims I'm heading to
paradise. So do you believe that that
that is right? Of course because the
Muslim have certainty and the knowledge
that that is not doesn't mean it's
arrogant. For example now give example
if someone told
me or if I told some if someone says for
example what's your name?
If someone if if I said is right in
front of me now I'm speaking to him.
Yeah. If someone comes and he said no
the one that you speaking to is not here
cuz in China women
regardless how many proofs he's going to
claim to have. I will never listen and
entertain what he's going to say because
the knowledge I have about you that I'm
speaking to you right now is so certain.
You understand? Right. So when it comes
to Islam and this the beauty of Islam
and what distinguish Islam from any way
of life and any religion, Islam is not
based upon assumption or dreams or or
guesswork. Islam is based upon knowledge
and certainty. That's why in Islam when
we say we believe it's not a belief that
some European use for you're not sure.
No when we say we believe mean I have a
knowledge and I'm certain. Okay. So
you're certain that So when you say
certainty, you are certain that you are
going to paradise. No, no, no, no.
You're certain of what? Of the truth.
I'm certain of Islam is the truth. And
I'm certain that if I follow what Allah
told me to follow and and stay away from
Allah told me to stay away from I'm
certain I go to paradise. However, as a
normal human being, I don't know the
future. Anything can happen in the
future. Maybe, you know, we maybe
someone attacks me in this. That's why
we Muslims will always humble ourselves
to Allah Almighty by sayingshah.
Okay. When we say we are doubting Islam.
No, we are saying because we know
everything is the hand of Allah not in
our hands. Right. So
now that Allah does not forgive that
partners are associated with him but he
forgives everything. So me knowing that
I'm a person who's upon the earth. Yeah.
I'm a person that walks the earth and I
know this is a testing ground, right?
Mankind has been sent here to be tested.
The testing ground. So this is a testing
ground. Yeah. And I know I'm supposed to
be tested here. Yeah. And I know I've
been given a book. I've been given
guidance on walking that path. Even
though test and 12 might come. Yeah. As
long as I follow that track correctly,
paradise at the end. Yes. I know I might
trip as the prophet mentioned he
mentioned all of the sons of Adam. All
of us are children of Adam. All of them
they they they they make the best of
those who are those who turn back to
their Lord in repentance. A person walks
with certainty I might earn trip here
and there and I know as long as I walk
back I turn back in repentance and try
and turn away from that which I earned
and slipped in and it's at the end.
Okay. And I'm following his guidance.
It's clear. It's not confusing. Yeah.
It's not ambiguous. So in certain so in
reality you can have certainty in Islam.
Certainty of salvation. We walk with
that. Yeah. That that certainty in terms
of ourselves. I'm not certain that I
will definitely have to as long as I
walk the Okay. Now what Shamzi just said
right? I want to apply that same
principle to myself in the scriptures
that I study. I believe that it is the
truth of God. Besides, no before we get
there, the scripture that I study, I
believe that it is the truth of God. So
if I go by what Shamsey just said, when
somebody What compels you to believe?
Say again. What compels you to believe
it's the truth of God? What compels me?
Yes. To believe it's the truth. What
compels me? Two things. First, I've
proven the the the
the on the basis of the prophetic word,
the prophecies of the word. And the
second, my personal experience. Were
these prophecies backed up by previous
prophecies?
Yes prophesies the same prophets. So for
example in in the book of Isaiah it's
pro in Isaiah and the book of Daniel for
example both prophesied of Jesus. The
time Jesus would be on earth. The time
Jesus would die. These are prophecies
that took place. Now remember Daniel
lived 500 years before Jesus. He
prophesied the time that Jesus the
Messiah would be on earth. That prophecy
came to pass exactly the way he said. So
I can take that as confidence that this
word can be trusted. You get what I'm
saying? All of the word. All exactly.
Say again. All of the word. So, hold on
a second. Hold on a second. Before you
get in, let's just finish this in. So,
so when I take these prophecies and I
look at them, Isaiah 53, for example,
speaking of the one who's going to be
led as a lamb to the slaughter, I take
those prophecies personally of what God
has done for me to save me. That's your
interpretation. That was So now, so
that's where we're going to So, so, so
no, no, no. So, that's where we're going
to go. message can prophets can read
message clear messages that to be
followed. Remember the lay man must be
able to follow it. I I'm a lame man. All
of
us man must be able to follow it. Your
interpretation based interpretation but
I can say the same about you brother. It
never came because this is one of the
reasons why you follow the prophet and
his companions and those who follow that
way. That was not based on
interpretation. That was him revelation.
They were acting upon that revelation
and then having certainty about it.
Okay, let let me summarize what I'm
saying. I believe by faith, God willing,
as he said, inshallah,
I believe by faith that when the
Almighty returns, by his grace, I'm
going to enter paradise. Return the
second coming of Jesus. So, you were
saying that Jesus is the Lord.
Why are you going there?
Because ambiguous. I mean, he prayed. I
mean I mean let's let's be let's be
honest here. Anytime you come to
speaker's corner you're going to go to
that discussion. Let's talk about what
we just discussed. My discussion. Oh no
fair play. Okay then you know my idea.
Well you know what I've just spoken
about Christ. What I'm saying is so but
hold on. It sounds like what you want to
believe. It sounds like desire is what
you want to believe. You said I believe
this because I I believe this. You
didn't show any like proof or evidence.
I've just given you guys in fact in fact
I was Christian before and I studied it.
Let me let me give you something. Right.
If I take a 10, if I take a plastic bag,
one key